antoine bonjour quel est le programme de
cette journée qui s'annonce historique
où il aurait bien comme vous pouvez le
voir je suis en situation idéale pour
assister à l'arrivée des deux des deux
présidents juste devant l'entrée le
perron de cette ville à la grange se
sera pas avant 13h vladimir poutine vous
l'avez dit n'est pas encore arrivé à
genève ce sera le cas sur le coup de
midi et nuit il rejoindra ensuite
directement cette ville à la grange où
il sera accueilli par le président de la
confédération suisse guy parmelin dont
la foulée ce sera au tour de joe biden
d'arrivée ensuite ce sera le tour du
protocole le protocole ce sera le moment
pour les deux délégations de se voir et
le moment également de trouver joe biden
et vladimir poutine dans la même pièce
une première pour joe biden au moins en
tant que président des états unis ce
sera véritablement à ce moment là que
vont commencer les tractations les
négociations entre les deux camps des
discussions qui risque de durer une
bonne partie de l'après midi il y a deux
conférences de presse qui sont prévues
en fin de journée a priori vers 18h pour
vladimir poutine et 18h30 pour joe biden
et voilà tous ces horaires sont donnés à
titre indicatif bien entendu la
situation peut évoluer au cours de la
journée on sait que joe biden est déjà
sur place
quelle est l'ambiance à genève ce matin
ouais bien pour parvenir jusqu'à cette
ville à la grange nous avons parcouru
tout le centre ville de genève et
c'était très étrange de voir toutes ces
rues vides vides à l'exception de très
nombreuses forces de l'ordre qui se
trouve littéralement à chaque coin de
rue de nombreux barrages policiers
également qui laisse filtrer uniquement
les véhicules autorisés de même pour le
contrôle de sécurité à l'entrée de ce
parc la grange un contrôle très
minutieux les autorités suisses n'ont
laissé n'ont laissé aucun doute on était
très minutieuse dans l'organisation de
ce sommet est dorénavant je peux vous
parler également de cette atmosphère qui
règne au niveau du centre de presse
alors les différents médias termine de
s'installer lord l'atmosphère est
studieuse encore assez décontracté mais
nul doute que la pression va monter au
fur et à mesure de la matinée jusqu'à
arriver à sans aucun doute
l'effervescence au moment de l'arrivée
des présidents environ vers 13 heures
merci beaucoup
antoine gayraud antoine en direct du
domaine ville à la grange à genève